another gunman leaves dead and wounded
behind in a shooting spree on a college
campus President Joe Biden who last year
signed the first major gun restrictions
in 30 years cited the shootings as
evidence that more needs to be done and
soon we have to do something to stop gun
violence ripping apart our communities
there is no rationale
for assault weapons police have found no
reason or connection we have absolutely
no idea what the motive was at this
point we can confirm that the 43 year
old suspect had no affiliation to the
university the answers might have
perished with the suspect shown in this
police photo Who police say fatally shot
himself as they were closing in on him
everyone's crying and just as we freshly
blockaded the doors apparently people
heard shooting they heard the door open
and it's this giant Stampede of people
headed toward me the latest shooting
terrorizing the town of East Lansing is
hundreds of officers searched for the
gunman left emotions Raw
we uh received a lot of texts that were
just uh you know I'm on my way just
within people showing up where do you
need me yeah it was it was it was a sad
but uh
very proud night for all of us here as
parents we tell our kids it's gonna be
okay
we say that all the time
but the truth is words are not good
enough
we must act and we will
in Michigan many students are returning
home their University a crime scene I am
currently directly across the street
from where the shootings at Michigan
State occurred
I am 21 years old and this is the second
mass shooting that I have not lived
through
10 years and two months ago I survived
the Sandy Hook shooting the fact that
this is the second mass shooting that I
have now lived through is
incomprehensible
the U.S Congress remains mired in a
decades-long dispute over the right to
bear arms as the daily Carnage continues
John hendren Al Jazeera